we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p i got a
voicemail suggesting that what may be
best for the progressive movement is for
donald trump to stay in office let's
take a listen to it
hi there i'm a progressive with an
unpopular opinion in regards to the
impeachment of donald trump my personal
opinion is that we need to keep them
keep him in the oval office as long as
possible
if you ever want to secure something
like medicare for all yeah this is not
as unpopular a position as the caller
seems to think i've suggested not
specifically for medicare for all I
think that Trump in the White House may
not do anything one way or the other for
Medicare for all I've been saying for a
while that what may ultimately be best
is for a scandal-ridden Trump to stay in
rather than turning the reins over to
Mike Pence either through resignation or
impeachment and that over the long term
that's what might catalyze more activism
and lead to the best outcome for the
left in 2020 oh the argument around
Medicare for all I'm not sure I fully
understand but actually I know a lot of
people who believe this so it's not a
fringe perspective and it's not an
unpopular perspective it's just more one
of their are the political implications
of impeachment or resignation and then
there's also is impeachment the right
thing is resignation the right thing and
you have to consider them both
separately but they also have to be
considered sort of an in concert with
each other on today's bonus show Piers
Morgan says that he should be Donald
Trump's new chief of staff we're going
to talk about McDonald's taking a stand
on antibiotic use in beef production and
we will also talk about the CFO from I'm
not sure how it's pronounced is it
Huawei who has been granted bail in
Canada Huawei and we will be talking
about that and much more on today's
bonus show how do you get access to the
bonus show very easy become a member
ww join pakman.com become a patron for
at least five bucks a month patreon.com
slash david pakman show
we will speak to you on the bonus show
in just minutes hope you're gonna be
there